I feel very well warm welcome to you now
this company I was mentioning there Oleg
Deripaska is an iminium business Roussel
50% wiped off the value now that's four
and a half billion dollars why such a
big response just explain how these
sanctions bite well basically what the
US Treasury is saying is that the u.s.
doesn't want anybody any American but
but a lot of people connected to America
to do business with Oleg Deripaska or
his company and this is a big
international company they're doing
business with in dollars with people all
over the world policies are typically
dollar denominated and on top of that
these people have debt that they have to
pay in dollars and so it basically
paralyzes the company I think there must
there probably are dozens of lawyers
right now in an emergency meeting trying
to figure out what they can do what they
can't do anybody who's doing business
with this company has got to figure out
do they want to be in violation of
sanctions if they pay them back money
they owe them if they're doing contracts
with them everything grinds to a halt
and so it creates an enormous amount of
uncertainty and it probably cuts off a
lot of business now when we got this
announcement on on Friday afternoon I
can imagine what you've probably thought
about it but there was originally a
watch list wasn't there and in January I
think the US government issued it where
there are about 200 different either
entities or individuals on it what was
the rationale for how these that have
targeted people and institutions were
picked well it's not clear what was
inside their minds when they picked them
cuz I wasn't there but if you look at
who was picked these are people who all
have very close relationships with
Vladimir Putin Oleg Deripaska is a total
insider same thing with all the other
characters and and also all these
characters all these people have some
type of issue so in the case of
Deripaska there's the whole mana 4 issue
in the case of Suleiman Kareem off he
was under arrest in France in the case
of Vekselberg he was at the inauguration
of Trump so there's all some that
there's always there's something
specific and unique about each of these
people who are on on this list and when
it comes close to Putin and presumably
what
as it come it bites financially well
what what the purpose of this is that
Vladimir Putin that they didn't want to
just go after people close to Putin they
wanted to get to Putin and some of these
oligarchs are trustees for Vladimir
Putin Putin is a very rich man he has a
lot of money and he doesn't hold the
money in his own name he holds the money
in names of oligarch trustees and so
some of the people on the list are
holding money for Putin and so
effectively the United States government
has sanctioned Putin and we know what
the United States is doing they've made
this this bold move but what about
questions around companies closer to
homes they've got Glencore for example
big footsie 100 companies got a stake in
Russo listed on the London Stock
Exchange and also VP has a stake in
Rosneft well this is this creates a real
problem vp is is got a possible future
problem Glencore has got a current
problem which is what do you what do you
do in a situation when you're a global
international company with lots of
business with the united states and you
have an investment in a US sanctioned
company it's it creates an enormous
headache problem and potential liability
for Glencore would you expect a UK
government response well I think that I
mean let's let's look at the situation
there was there was a a Russian
terrorist attack using military-grade
chemical weapons in Salisbury and it's
the American sanctioning the Russians
not the Brits I mean so I Theresa May
has to cut step up to the plate and do
the same thing that the Americans do
have done here if she doesn't it sets an
enormous welcomemat to do more terrorist
attacks with impunity
I suppose the the other thing about the
American response is this is just a very
small proportion of the original list so
presumably they can and probably will
continue to go further well and that's a
very important point because there's
only 7 out of those 200 people and and
they don't want to sanction everybody in
one go they want to they want to both
create a punishment and create a massive
disincentive for future bad acts and by
only doing 7 they're saying you know we
could do 8 9 10 11 12 the next time
and and and that and and and it's the
message of latter in Putin's which is
you know don't do any of this bad stuff
anymore because now we're coming after
your money
and how painful is what's already
happened do you think for president I
think it's very painful I think this is
the first real serious act of sanctions
since Russia invaded Crimea this is this
is the thing that really touches him
personally okay alright well we owe that
well watch to see won't may bill Brown
it very good to talk to you thank you
thank you